figure lie bonjour il est 17h on vit en
ce moment les dernières heures du
mercato d'été 2021 ce mercato le jour le
plus long pour les fans de football je
sais avec sébastien ferra salut
sébastien s'allument dans le sens tu vas
bien ouais ça va bien tu as suivi à peu
près toute la journée les informations
on va donner un peu faire le point sur
ce qui est sorti aujourd'hui ce qui va
arriver en rumeurs les dossiers qu'on
continue de suivre toute la journée et
on va commencer peut-être par le gros
dossier de ces derniers jours qui a
priori a priori ne devrait plus bouger
ses suites qu'il y avait une barbe est
vrai qu'il ya ma peur qu'on a longtemps
annoncé au real madrid s'est beaucoup
parlé ces derniers jours où on avait des
offres du real madrid qui devenait plus
ou moins officielles en tout cas qu'ils
n'arrêtaient pas de filtrer dans la
presse et finalement à priori le psg a
tenu bon et le real madrid a laissé
tomber pour pomper donc a priori mba
paix devrait rester au paris
saint-germain former cette fameuse
attaque avec messi neymar
c'était pas forcément partie pour ça ces
derniers jours comment on peut expliquer
ce revirement non mais c'est vrai que
c'est parti un petit peu un petit peu
dans tous les sens où un coup un coup
paris semblait plutôt bien parti pour
conserver mbappé un coup le real
semblait avoir repris l'aventage c'était
assez assez floue bas pkk jamais
communiqué sur le sujet mais qui ne
cachait plus vraiment cessé envie de
partir en tout cas il cachait plus qu'il
n'allait pas prolonger et donc il
poussait vraiment le psg à le vendre et
en même temps on l'a vu contre contre
reims lors du premier match de messi ou
c'est qu'il y ait un bape et qui donne
la victoire d'un doublé et qui a l'air
très très bien dans cette équipe qui est
grand sourire qui célèbre ses buts il
n'a pas du tout l'attitude d'un joueur
sur le départ finalement le real madrid
a eu beau monter son offre à environ 200
millions d'euros le psg a tenu bon on va
saluer allen hugo et s'ils disent qu'ils
nous ont rejoints sur le chat de youtube
vous hésitez pas pendant ce live à nous
poser vos questions on va essayer d'y
répondre si vous voulez avoir des infos
sur des joueurs sur des clubs nouveau
club de coeur ce que vous supportez on
essaiera de vous donner tous tout ce
qu'on sait a priori maintenant sur ce
mercato alors qu'on est à cette heure de
la fin du mercato il en cette heure il
peut se passer beaucoup de choses dans
un mercato oui oui post passé peut se
passer plein de choses on l'a vu on
l'avait toutes ces années on le voit
encore aujourd'hui beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui se passent encore par deux
têtes gaëtan laborde qui est encore sur
le départ de montpellier qui pourrait
finir à rennes eduardo cas mavinga qui
n'est pas encore un joueur du real
madrid mais a priori ça ne saurait
tarder il va se passer encore plein de
choses on va suivre un peu tous et où
tous ces dossiers là qu'à ma vie bien
justement c'est le gros transfert a
priori de cette fin de mercato niveau
français
cavalia qui devrait normalement aller au
real de madrid d'ici ce soir oui a
priori d'ici ce soir ce sera fait son
départ est pas une énorme surprise parce
que ça en prenait vraiment le chemin
petit à petit à rennes surtout parce que
il y avait le sujet d'une possible
prolongation de contrat on rappelle que
kamal india il fait partie de tous ces
joueurs qui sont en fin de contrat en
juin prochain c'est le cas de kim bape
et de paul pogba pour ne citer qu'eux
forcément s'il n'est pas prolongé pour
rennes ça veut dire soit le vendre
maintenant et empocher un petit peu
d'argent soit le voir partir
gratuitement dans un an
ils choisissent de le vendre maintenant
illusion pas vraiment vraiment le choix
je pense en même temps je pense aussi
que cabinda et son entourage ont pas mal
poussé en tout cas pour pour un départ
quand c'est le real madrid qui toquent à
la porte c'est difficile de dire non a
priori que mavinga sera madrilène ce
soir c'est la vie aussi de moria qui
nous dit je pense qu avant minuit
signera au real madrid à priori oui
effectivement sachant que calvin bien en
plus sort d'une saison quand même assez
compliquée avec rennes ça et c'est ça a
été on se rappelle de l'an dernier on
peut dire un peu la hype y avait autour
de ce joueur qui était quand même assez
après une première sélection chez les
grandes en équipe de france il venait de
remporter la coupe de france avec rennes
c'était c'était assez fort et l'a
finalement le real le récupère pour 40
millions devrait récupérer en tout cas
c'est ça oui 30 40 millions c'est un peu
les chiffres qu'il filtre alors c'est
vrai qu'à mavinga on l'a vu il a explosé
alors qu'il n'était même pas encore
majeur il avait encore 17 ans avec
rennes et déjà ils faisaient les grands
matches face au psg de marco garatti
pour ne citer que lui au milieu de
terrain il avait l'impression de
vraiment de surnager en ligue 1 derrière
il ya eu cette saison 2021 on n'a pas
reconnu la même fraîcheur la même
énergie là le même volume à rennes même
si en équipe de france ça a été aussi
assez impressionnant de le voir bien
adapté au groupe de le voir marquer
aussi il avait battu un record de
précocité pour un but en équipe de
france ne publie depuis l'après-guerre
cavigal sort d'une saison compliquée
forcément sa cote à la bbc il avait plus
qu'un an de contrat c'était difficile
pour m d'en tirer une somme une seule
comparé la cdn bape est par exemple qui
a un âge finalement pas très différent
qui donc on parle de somme de 150 200
millions d'euros bah forcément qu'elle
allume gaz c'est encore un cran en
dessous et il abat malheureusement il
n'a pas confirmé comme on l'espérait à
rennes alors sait on à britney qui le
dit ça sent le flop est ce que parce que
comme l'iphone donc le rappeler il sort
d'une saison compliquée à rennes est ce
que c'était juste de passage avec on
imagine toute la pression qui peut y
avoir sur sur ce joueur au moment de la
deux couleurs ou les plus grands clubs
vont vers vous et vous demande voilà on
veut recruter peut-être que ça lui a
peut-être un peu fait perdre les pédales
ou un peu son niveau de jeu est-ce que
c'est passager ou est ce que il peut
redevenir le joueur avec comme le disait
beaucoup de fraîcheur de 10 à 2 ans bien
sûr il ya un an déjà on parlait du de
l'intérêt du real madrid pour kaka
vinales a forcément ça met beaucoup de
pression quand on est à peine majeur et
qu'on doit supporter ça qu'on doit jouer
avec ça qu'on doit encore se
familiariser au monde professionnel que
tout le monde tout le monde l'a mis sur
un piédestal et la considérer comme un
des meilleurs milieux de terrain de
ligue 1 voir les milieux de terrain
français
forcément c'est très difficile à
encaisser est ce que ce sera un flop
c'est qu'on peut pas on ne peut pas le
prédire aujourd'hui évidemment mais j'ai
vu une comparaison assez intéressante
qui était faite avec ousmane dembélé
c'est intéressant en plus parce que tous
les deux ont joué à rennes dembélé aussi
a connu une ascension fulgurante au
marseille n'a jamais confirmé notamment
pour des raisons de blessure qui l'a
empêché d'enchaîner les matches mais il
faut faire attention à ce que qu'a
mavinga ne prennent pas cette direction
là qui n'est pas un côté rejoindre un
grand club trop tôt trop vite qu'ils ne
soient pas prêts en tout cas à franchir
le cap surtout mentalement parce que sur
le reste on l'a vu tactiquement
techniquement il a montré des choses la
jouer ces matchs où il a performé ces
matchs ils ont existé c'est pas du vent
maintenant il faut assurer mentalement
il faut suivre c'est quand même un
énorme bond en avant dans la carrière de
cannes avignon ils passent effectivement
de rennes au real madrid que de peu
d'attention comme ça qui sont aussi
fulgurant trouve à dire on passe pas par
la club 2 de milieu de tableau entre
guillemets c'est ça oui c'est rennes
c'est un club plus de ligue europa voire
ligue europa conférence comme comme
cette saison car elle joue la ligue des
champions mais bon on a vu que c'était
malheureusement pas leur place ou du
moins pas encore forcément jouer au real
madrid là c'est une toute autre pression
c'est un tout autre prestige la ses
coéquipiers au milieu de terrain ça
pourrait dès casimiro luka modric toni
kroos on parle de joueurs prétendants
voir ballon d'or
forcément c'est un autre niveau il va
jouer avec le karim benzema aussi un
compatriote il est entraîné par carlo
ancelotti je pense que si on l'avait dit
ça il ya deux trois ans je sais pas si
cabinda il y aurait cru c'est une très
bonne nouvelle pour lui pour sa carrière
c'est une belle opportunité
effectivement et honda sylvie qui nous
pose pas mal de questions et nous pour
une première dit ce soir qu'il y en
aurait été ratée de vraiment au psg
à priori oui à priori oui même si on
maintenant on voit que tout est possible
jusqu'au dernier moment
maintenant le psg semble avoir tenu bon
les dernières informations de la presse
française ou espagnole c'est que le real
madrid a laissé tomber pour clients de
ba paix c'est que le real madrid est
monté jusqu'à je crois 200 millions
d'euros en tout cas c'est ce que c'était
c'était un petit peu ce qui était ce qui
était avancé a priori le real madrid
n'ira pas au delà et préférera attendre
un an pour avoir quilliam bape est libre
à la fin de son contrat au paris saint
germain à moins que le bape et prolonge
bien sûr on peut toujours imaginer tout
est possible bien sûr mais ça n'en prend
pas du tout la direction ça fait plus
d'un an que me battais a laissé traîner
ce dossier là de cette prolongation
son chausson soit il est clair il veut
jouer au real madrid que ce soit
maintenant que ce soit plus tard on voit
qu'il n'a pas plus fort c'est que ça non
plus pour pour partir au real tout de
suite il acceptait de jouer contre reims
il a assuré la mine d'oublier ils
étaient très contents tout allait bien
il va jouer sa saison au psg a priori il
partira ensuite au real madrid oddo real
madrid libre c'est clairement la
direction servent aujourd'hui après des
actions effectives blu ray ce que pour
le coup le psg ça peut être une erreur
de leur part de laisser partir un joueur
comme ça aussi alors qu'ils pourraient
en tirer 200 millions l'année d'avant et
là cette année là pour un an de plus on
s'assoit sur 200 millions c'est quand
même énorme oui c'est énorme c'est ccc
une colossale ses proches du prix du
plus gros transfert de l'histoire à
savoir celui de neymar de 222 millions
d'euros
refusez ça pour ne toucher que zéro euro
bah forcément ça fait une énorme
différence maintenant la question c'est
est-ce que le psg peut se permettre de
s'asseoir sur une telle somme
dans l'absolu je pense que le psg a les
fonds et se remettra d'une perte d'une
perte entre guillemets par manque à
gagner plutôt de 200 millions d'euros
maintenant si jamais ça pouvait entrer
en compte dans le fair play financier on
sait que le fair-play financier a été
beaucoup allégé cette année en raison de
la crise donc peut-être que le psg avait
un peu mis un peu moins besoin de vendre
et d'encaisser cet argent mais si ça
pouvait entrer en compte pas forcément
sa facilité les choses ensuite pour
d'autres recrues pour réinjecter de
l'argent
c'est quand même un choix fort du psg de
s'asseoir sur cette somme là
sportivement il tente le coup avec messi
neymar bape et en attaque et tout le
reste de leur effectif un peu super star
c'est quand même un choix assez fort je
pense du psg mais je suis pas sûr que le
psg puisse être vraiment gagnant sur le
long terme parce que je pense que une
prolongation sauf si vraiment il ya un
incroyable rebondissement dans la tête
de noeud pap et finalement ici qui n'ira
jamais au real madrid mais apparemment
il a pris il en rêve il va le faire
l'année prochaine ça devrait aller nous
verrons ce qui se passera à la prochaine
au prochain mercato d'été ça serait ce
ce se jouer à ce moment là on a star 2
qui nous parle de jerome boateng on va
parler un peu plus tard juste avant je
voulais prendre la question de sylvie
cela pose une question tout à l'heure
sur le retour de cristiano ronaldo à
united ça pour le coup il aurait fallu
être très fort pour prévoir ça oui oui
ça c'était assez difficile à prévoir et
même il ya encore et encore il ya encore
une semaine en tout cas jusqu'à ce que
l'intérêt de manchester united filtre
jusque là ronaldo semblait clairement
partir pour manchester city pour le
grand rival alors qu'elle lui a joué
pendant je crois six ans à manchester
united au dernier moment un petit peu il
y en ait s'est finalement réveillé dans
le dossier s'est manifestée le choix
finalement il a semble-t-il été assez
rapide pour ronaldo en tout cas entre
rejoindre son club ce club qu'il aime
tant qu' à qui il a rendu qui l'a amené
au sommet du football et le rival
l'ennemi juré le choix il a été assez
assez limpide on pourrait parler
beaucoup sportivement de l'apport de
ronaldo est ce que ça va vraiment
marcher à manchester united est ce que
c'est pas un petit peu trop
offensivement est ce que c'est un si bon
choix finalement de unitaid de le
récupérer mais en tout cas je pense que
c'est un peu un soulagement pour ronaldo
parce qu'à la juventus clairement il
avait un peu le sentiment d'avoir
d'avoir touché le plafond et qu'il
allait un petit peu dans le mur
maintenant on va quand même se retrouve
avec une équipe de man united qui va
être assez effrayante on va dire on a
quand même ronaldo fernandez dans la
curée sancho ils ont récupéré varane
juste avant ça fait quand même
énormément de bons joueurs recrutés lors
de ce mercato c'est quand même vraiment
pas mal oui sur le mercato c'est très
fort on rappelle que au début de l'été
on parlait beaucoup d'un possible départ
de paul pogba et au final paul pogba
reste et on ramène ronaldo sans le show
varane le mercato quand même dommage
qu'il ait été très impressionnant en
tout cas sur le papier après on verra
évidemment si ça si ça prend forme pour
raphaël varane je pense qu'on peut être
assez confiant mais j'adore une seule
chaud il ya peut-être un petit peu plus
de brouillard autour de cristiano
ronaldo parce qu'il a 36 ans est ce que
on sait que ce ne sera pas le même
ronaldo qu'on a déjà vu d'abord à
manchester united et la question aussi
sait comment organiser cette équipe
maintenant avec effectivement bruno
fernandes jadden sochaux cristiano
ronaldo qui ont l'air d'être 3
indiscutable en attaque il faut faire
jouer aussi paul pogba alors il ya la
question de le faire jouer assez haut ou
un petit peu plus bas en même temps il
faut peut-être pas faire jouer que des
joueurs offensifs même si au niveau de
cette équipe voilà c'est ça c'est
qu'aussi il ya une paire à manchester
united en milieu de terrain qui
s'appelle mac thominet et fred qui sont
très très bon milieu de terrain se
débarrasser de cette perte en enlever un
pour mettre pogba la place pour faire
reculer ça peut détruire tous les
équilibres de manchester united
tout remettre en question ils ont aussi
deux jeunes très intéressant avec marc
de stratford et mais seuls greenwood qui
très intéressant mais c'est les joueurs
qui commencent déjà à confirmer et qui
ont déjà un petit à petit statut à
manchester united ils vont avoir un peu
des problèmes de riche en tout cas olé
gunnar solskjaer va avoir vraiment ces
problèmes là mais je pense que ces
démons problème en tout cas ils
partaient pour avoir des problèmes un
peu plus un peu plus triste au début de
l'été donc je pense qu'il est content à
priori oui surtout que mon geste a fait
toujours boudé recrutement assez
important une rade là ça fait quelques
temps où c'était plus compliqué on a
parlé de cavani qui pourrait peut-être
aller au bal et au barça a priori ça ne
se fera pas de ce qu'on a vu sur les
dernières informations c'est assez
impressionnant en tout cas effectivement
leur recrutement on a aidé une question
du coût de stars d'as qui nous
demandaient eux sur sur le passage sur
assure jérôme boateng à l'ol en dépit de
sondages de nice en demeure une
référence à son poste il apportera
davantage de solidité et de compacité
que son homologue brésilien marcelo
alors effectivement marcelo n'était
peut-être pas c'est quand même pas le
même niveau après un peu boiteux n'y ait
plus vieux mais boateng pour être une
vraie vraie bonne pioche pour lyon bien
sûr alors je pense que si on avait dit
au début de l'été aux supporters
lyonnais qu'ils allaient remplacer
marcelo par jérôme boateng je pense
qu'ils auraient signé tout de suite
après c'est vrai que jérôme boateng il
ya un peu des questions sur son physique
c'est notamment une des raisons pour
lesquelles le bayern munich a décidé de
ne pas prolonger après dix ans de bons
et loyaux services
boateng c'est un défenseur inexpérience
monstrueuse il a gagné la ligue des
champions il a gagné la coupe du monde
il a un peu là un peu tout gagné
finalement au bayern munich en terme
d'expérience de vécu de ce qui peut
apporter aux vestiaires je pense qu'on
est au moins dix crans au dessus de
marcelo qui pour le coup d'après ce
qu'ils avaient filtré justement le
problème c'était surtout ce qui l'a
porté au vestiaire qui était plus
négatif que positif sur le terrain on
verra si boateng est capable d'enchaîner
le match on verra si ça se fait bel et
bien en tout cas ça part vraiment dans
le bon sens pour lyon d'après ce que
nous disait le journal l'équipe c'est
quand même une bonne recrue en tout cas
dans les dernières heures du mercato se
rabattre sur jérôme boateng il ya
vraiment pire pour lol effectivement ils
pourront ils auraient pu trouver bien
sylvie qui dit cavani une pièce
maîtresse de manchester cavani est une
pièce maîtresse mais il c'était une
pièce maîtresse est ce que ça peut le
rester dans une équipe où effectivement
on récupère on récupère ronaldo et où on
joue déjà avec anthony martial alors
effectivement cavani je dirais que
peut-être pas pièces maîtresses mais en
tout cas il a rendu de fiers services
quand même la saison dernière que ce
soit en tant que remplaçant au départ
pour entrer en jeu ou même titulaire il
a marqué quelques précieux but quand
même à manchester on pouvait se demander
de s'il allait performer après un départ
assez en mauvais termes avec avec le psg
je trouve qu'il a vraiment tout cas
réussi pour l'instant son passage à
manchester united maintenant quand
cristiano ronaldo arrive a vraiment
donné le club doit faire des choix
c'est déjà on parlait de l' équilibre à
garder avec marcus trash ford et nissan
greenwood qui sont déjà des joueurs qui
sont c'est difficile de les mettre sur
le banc et de les écarter un peu du onze
de départ derrière cavani et martial où
il a abandonné il va falloir qu'elle y
en a qui s'en aille parce que certains
ne nous vont juste pas jouer un joueur
comme cristiano ronaldo un joueur comme
bruno fernandes sont des joueurs qui
jouent tous les matches qui enchaîne
sans arrêt
je pense pas que le départ de cavani
soit si préjudiciable ça peut quand même
être une bonne solution en sortie de
banc à choisir je pense que manchester
devrait peut-être plutôt se séparer d'un
anthony martial même si après ça peut ça
dépend finalement de ce que olé gunnar
solskjaer décide dans le profil peut
être qu'un cavani aujourd'hui ressemble
plus à un ronaldo un peu joueur vraiment
de surface pur buteur alors qu'anthony
martial a su apporter des qualités un
petit peu au-delà de ça dans le jeu le
manchester night elle sera obligée de
faire un choix devra peut-être même
aussi un choix de maillots à faire parce
qu'on rappelle cavaignac numéro 7 qui a
priori n'a pas voulu laisser à jadson
seul show quand ils arrivent et je pense
que c'est quand même ronaldo là il va
peut-être falloir falloir y réfléchir
deux fois nous arrive dans une équipe il
faut quand même laissé numéro 7 ça se
passe comme ça on a remporté deux prix
de barcelone justement on en interne qui
me demande est-ce que emerson et moriba
vont-ils quitter le barça je sais que
les personnes c'est je crois que c'est
officiel pour tottenham le latéral de
latéral droit il joue latéral droit miss
à emerson royal et moriba je crois qu'il
devrait rejoindre la piste mais je sais
pas si c'est officiel pour les deux en
tout cas moriba a priori était allé
psych il était filmé à l'epci gens qui
passaient juste sa visite médicale mais
ça va bien se faire oui les deux joueurs
vont quitter le barça c'est acté ils
seront plus barcelonais à partir de
demain c'est certain il lâche moriba
pour le coup c'est quand même un coup
dur pour le barça c'est pas très joli en
étant on peut difficilement ou vouloir
au barça parce qu'a priori en tout cas
des infiltrations des informations qui
ont filtré les prétentions salariales de
moriba ou du moins de son entourage
était particulièrement élevé pour un
joueur de 18 ans tient à peine 20
matches en professionnel
c'était difficile de lui offrir un pont
d'or même si c'est vrai que c'est un
grand grand espoir du barça le barça va
quand même récupérer 15 millions d'euros
je crois à 15-20 millions d'euros sur un
joueur qu'ils ont formées il n'aura
pourtant pas beaucoup joué en
professionnel sur le papier on se dit
que le barça n'avait pas vraiment le
choix n'avait pas mieux à faire voilà et
récupérer une certaine somme le secteur
du barça en tout cas le secteur du
milieu de terrain il est assez
inquiétant il ya notamment certains
miralem pjanic qui arrivait ya un an qui
a un flop total pour le coup je pense
qu'on peut le dire car l'entraidé
annoncé sur le départ qui a priori va
rester finalement en catalogne
le départ de moriba en tout cas c'est
finalement une nouvelle autre mauvaise
nouvelle mais pour le coup je pense pas
qu'on peut de temps vouloir que ça au
barça on rappelle quand même que pjanic
arthur le petit transfert qui avait
permis d'équilibrer les comptes c'était
plus petites magouilles entre clubs un
petit mot pour équilibrer les comptes à
l'époque alors qu'il n'avait pas
forcément besoin
je regardais une question qui nous est
posée c'est de la part de flora qui nous
demandent quel avenir pour inédite
ferhat khirat joueur de nîmes qui était
très très bon parce qu'un joueur qui
surnage et on va dire un peu à nîmes
signy ferhat a priori on n'a pas de
nouvelles depuis là depuis le mercato
d'où il pourrait arriver ce qui pouvait
acheter ni mes dernières informations
c'est que strasbourg semblait plutôt en
pole position si jamais un club devait
récupérer ferhat a priori je crois que
c'était foot mercato qui disait ça que
bordeaux avait tout simplement informés
qu'ils n'étaient pas intéressés
effectivement la situation de ferhat
elle interroge parce que c'est un joueur
qui sort d'une vraie belle saison quand
même à nîmes en ligue 1 même si le club
il n'a pas pu éviter la relégation du
club c'est quand même un joueur qui a de
vraies qualités en tant que milieu
offensif qui peut guider une attaque qui
peut percuter qui devrait qualité on
voit en ligue 2 c'est étonnant qu'un tel
joueur ne soit pas ne soit pas dans
l'élite en france où l'un com se
positionne en tout cas pour aller de
récupérer oui voilà en tout cas qui est
un club où il se positionne et même si
c'est un club qui joue le maintien ça va
peut-être pas joué à l'om ou au psg
c'est sûr
mais effectivement c'est un an voilà
c'est effectivement assez intriguant de
voir qu'il est kiné qui met toujours en
ligue 2 effectivement donc voilà pour
dean ferhat on peut passer sur une
information qui est tombé dans l'après
midi on en parlait un peu avant le
direct jeu dont vous me croyez pas trop
trop au début et on sait toujours pas
vraiment si ça va se faire bien sûr mais
c'est un possible échange entre antoine
griezmann et hao félix est ce que toi ça
te paraît possible alors effectivement
quand on a vu l'information ce matin mme
avait de quoi de quoi être surpris
surtout que la première formation
c'était que le barça avait demandé à
l'atletico s'il était possible de se
faire prêter joao felix
sur le papier la formation un peu oui
surprenante c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire parce que l'atletico n'a pas
vraiment de raison de renforcer un
concurrent au titre comme ça avec un
joueur qui l'avait recruté pour 127
millions d'euros à l'été à l'été 2010
notons qu'il ya deux ans maintenant je
rêvais liste est vrai qu'il a un peu en
situation d'échec et c'est dans cette
optique que le barça aurait proposé un
échange antoine griezmann joao felix
qu'un peu un échange entre deux joueurs
qui sont en difficulté dans leurs clubs
et rim annonçait ça fait longtemps qu'il
est critique au barça sur ce début de
saison il se remet toujours pas la tête
à l'endroit le barça cherche à se
débarrasser de griezmann on le sent bien
déjà pendant l'été on en avait beaucoup
parlé d'un possible retour à l'atletico
finalement ça s'est pas fait il y avait
certains joueurs qui étaient cités dans
un possible échange le nom de joe félix
n'avait jamais filtré pour le coup
maintenant c'est le cas effectivement
sur le papier ce sont deux attaquants un
qui ont des profils plus ou moins
similaire peut-être grise même un peu
plus meneur de jeu jouent à félix est un
peu plus tourné vers le but un échange
pourquoi pas en tout cas financièrement
ça pourrait peut-être se tenir surtout
pour pour le barça je pense que le
salaire de joao felix est inférieur
celui de griezmann maintenant je pense
que l'atletico a un peu plus à perdre
dans cet échange c'est pas un hasard si
jamais c'est le barça qui vient voir
l'atletico pour proposer cet échange
parce qu'avec griezmann ils ont senti
qu'ils ne peuvent plus rien en tirer
qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils pouvaient qui
sont déjà arrivés au bout du parcours et
qu'avec jean félix ils peuvent peut-être
relancer une dynamique
donc voilà ce qu'ils vont pouvait dire
en tout cas sur cette possible sursaut
possible sur ce possible pardon possible
échange entre antoine griezmann et hao
félix on peut partir sur un autre sur un
autre dossier c'est un dossier français
pour le coup on ne parle aucune semaine
c'est jules kundé du kundé qui est
défenseur central parfois latéral en
équipe de france était joueur qui joue
au fc séville et qui est pisté par
chelsea depuis très longtemps et le
transfert ne se fait pas mine transfert
ne se fait pas alors que apparaît a
priori l'une des principales conditions
c'était le départ de kurt zouma de
chelsea à west ham ça ç'a bien été fait
qu'en somme a été vendu à west ham pour
30 millions d'euros donc ça permettait à
chelsea a priori de faire de la place
déjà dans l'effectif ajoute condé et
d'avoir vraiment le budget pour le
recruter ensuite finalement ça ne prend
pas la direction ces villes qui a
vraiment fait monter les enchères et qui
réclame à priori en tout cas de ce que
dit la presse espagnole 80 millions
d'euros pour jeu kundé effectivement là
c'est un prix qui commencent à un peu
élevé pour pour chelsea qui a déjà mis
une centaine de millions d'euros sur
romelu lukaku
jeu le kundé c'est un titulaire
indiscutable à séville il a été en est
il a été appelé en équipe de france il
l'avait bien mérité il était un peu un
peu de temps en temps il a il
impressionné d'abord à bordeaux et
ensuite à séville en liga et s'est fait
un nom on a vu le barça le real qui
s'intéressaient à lui maintenant je
pense que c'est pas une mauvaise
nouvelle pour lui de rester à séville
dans un club qui va jouer la ligue des
champions qui se rapproche de plus en
plus d'un statut de prétendant au titre
surtout avec le léger déclin du barça et
du real je ne pense pas que ce soit une
mauvaise nouvelle pour je ne connais ni
pour l'équipe de france en tout cas
alors je vous demandais juste dans le
chat du site du figaro 2 2 voilà de
rester courtois entre vous bien
évidemment parce que voilà je vois que
ça ne parle pas beaucoup de foot et que
vous voilà dans les commentaires vous
êtes un peu véhément les uns envers les
autres on à christopher qui nous parle
de boîtes à gaoual on en a un peu parlé
rapidement on peut on peut-être en veut
dire un petit mot boîte à gâteaux elle
serait quand même une très bonne affaire
pour oui ça serait une bonne affaire
parce que ça reviendrait un petit peu
dans l'idée a remplacé marcelo par
jérôme boateng donc c
et c'est une énorme c'est un énorme
apport qualitatif en comparaison jerome
boateng il a un énorme vécu au bayern
munich il a tout gagné il a gagné la
coupe du monde avec l'allemagne il a un
petit peu fait le tour maintenant il a
eu pas mal de problèmes physiques c'est
un peu l'inquiétude c'est en tout cas
l'inquiétude qui avait le bayern munich
c'est pour ça qu'ils ne l'avaient pas
prolonger maintenant récupérer jérôme
boateng au dernier jour du mercato quand
on est vraiment galère de défenseur
central et qu'on récupère ça un peu au
dernier moment après avoir clairement à
la porte un joueur qui ne mettait pas un
pédalo qui ne mettait pas un pied devant
l'autre déjà sur le terrain et encore
plus dans le vestiaire
effectivement c'est quand même plutôt un
bon coup pour l'ol maintenant on verra
aussi financièrement le problème au
début c'était le possible salaire
forcément en boîte et nage au calme au
bayern munich il a une certaine
certaines prétentions salariales c'est
un joueur qui peut un peu coûter cher à
ce niveau là mais ça reste un joueur
gratuit en termes d'indemnités de
transfert c'est quand même plutôt un bon
coup pour l'ol on voit l'ol qui arrive
quand même cette année ils ont récupéré
shaqiri c'est quand même un coût assez
important je veux savoir un peu parce
qu'ils ont recruté un nouveau coach il
ya eu 10 lisons côté peterborough au
coaching quel est l'impact d'avoir un
coach qui comme ça car c'est un coach
qui est quand même très coté pour faire
venir des recrues on imagine que c'est
plus facile d'abord quand on est accro
coach reconnu qu'un coach comme bruno
genesio où rudi garcia bien sûr bien sûr
que c'est un impacte forcément parce que
peter bosch on a clairement compris ce
qu'ils voulaient mettre en place comment
il voulait jouer on a pu le voir au
bayer leverkusen il a une méthode assez
clair il a aussi une méthode très
franche très direct avec ses joueurs on
l'a vu sur le début de saison où il
n'hésite pas alors tiré dessus
publiquement à être très très cash en
conférence de presse forcément c'est un
petit peu d'attrait on peut prendre un
exemple un autre exemple en lien
christophe galtier à l'ogcnice on parle
beaucoup du mercato de l'ogcnice de très
bonnes recrues c'est pas un hasard si ça
se fait lorsque galtier est au club et
que galtier qui un vrai statut
d'entraîneur référence au delà même des
liens en europe forcément ça peut-être
de mandat rappelle de nous montrer
justement l'équipe l'équipe de nice
on voulait on voulait vous lui montrez
vous montrer un peu à quel point il on
en parlait un peu avant ce live ils ont
réussi quand même à se faire à
ce faire une équipe assez
impressionnante avec goldberg
dahlberg andy delort amine grichting
c'est quand même vraiment pas mal oui
sur le papier l'attaqué elle est très
impressionnante déjà récupéré dole berg
après son bond euros avec le danemark
c'était assez encourageant derrière il
ya eu les arrivées de calvin sting
d'andy delort à montpellier qui était
quand même pas mal courtisé notamment
par l'om oui sur le papier l'ogcnice à
une superbe attaque très bien mené par
un mini gris qu'on avait déjà vu la
saison dernière qu'on voit encore plus
sur ce début de saison nous gc nice en
ayant récupéré galtier derrière
parfaitement enclenché la machine du
mercato oui on est sur un club qui a
réussi son été en tout cas en france et
qui peut jouer vraiment je pense les
places européennes dès aujourd'hui alors
je vais te demander de décaler un tout
petit peu ce vote pour que tu puisse
passer mieux à la caméra et je vais vous
montrer effectivement l'équipe de
l'ogcnice si normalement les effectifs
sont à peu près à jour ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait certains plats du coup voilà
déjà c'est pas le bon
oui comme on le disait d'albert ii lors
après il y z'ont ils ont aussi quand
même un propriétaire qui a beaucoup
d'argent et avec lequel c'est plus
facile on va dire oui bien sûr c'est un
club qui aujourd'hui a les moyens
d'investir un petit peu à l'image par
exemple du stade rennais qui a pas mal
qui a pas mal investi cet été déjà l'été
précédent qui a commencé à avoir un
petit peu plus d'ambition aujourd'hui
logés si nissan est clairement un projet
ambitieux c'est un mot qui revenait
beaucoup dans la bouche d'ailleurs de
christophe galtier lorsqu'il est arrivé
à nice qu'il était vraiment séduit par
par ce projet tout cas qu'il ne
ressentait plus aujourd'hui à lille
lorsqu'il est parti
effectivement sur le papier ni c'est
très impressionnant il ya certains
joueurs qui étaient convoités un petit
peu partout en europe dans d'autres
clubs plutôt à ses côtés que ce soit en
allemagne ou en espagne ou en angleterre
l'ogcnice mais les ingrédients et en
tout cas à sur son ambition aujourd'hui
voilà avec que vous pouvez le voir andy
delort de le béa gorille un milieu
rosario les mines a du banc
effectivement avec
ah oui et
hop voilà bouddha week et freine thuram
qui a marqué le week-end dernier ils ont
quand même gagné 4 0 encore en encore ce
week end c'est assez impressionnant on a
une amende à une rumeur en fait de ces
derniers jours la kenyane qui nous parle
d'une rumeur du jour sur nuno mendes
nuno mendes au psg alors nuno mendes on
va reprendre le site du figaro mendes
qui est un latéral or il n'est pas très
connu en france est ce que tu peux nous
parler un peu de ce joueur d'abord oui
alors nuno mendes c'est donc un latéral
gauche du sporting portugal qui est
devenu international portugais cette
année qui a notamment été un petit peu
aperçu durant l'euro c'est un joueur qui
n'a que 18 ans encore aujourd'hui c'est
un joueur très précoce il a réalisé une
excellente saison au sporting il est
déjà très cotées ont parlé un petit peu
lui dans des gros clubs européens que ce
soit en angleterre ou en italie
aujourd'hui c'est un latéral gauche qui
a l'air d'avoir vraiment un énorme
potentiel alors il a très peu de saison
pro dont les gens vivent en a qu'une
seule vraiment complète donc c'est un
peu un pari sur l'avenir si jamais le pg
se lance sur lui on parle d'une somme de
40 millions d'euros c'est vraiment pas
rien pour un joueur qui n'a pas encore
eu le temps de beaucoup confirmé on
parlait tout à l'heure d'eduardo qu'un
mavinga peut-être que nuno mendes dans
sa progression est justement un peu au
niveau de cabinda après sa première
saison
c'est quand même vraiment un pari sur
l'avenir on parle de 40 millions d'euros
alors que on prend l'exemple du psg
achraf hakimi latéral droit qui a
vraiment fait ses preuves aline
terminant en a coûté 60 donc la somme
paraît quand même un petit peu un petit
peu élevé en tout cas il ya une petite
part de risque mais aujourd'hui oui nuno
mendes c'est un joueur qui semblent
comptés au poste d'arrière gauche et
c'est sûrement un joueur sur lesquels
les gros clubs vont se jeter dans l'est
dans les prochaines années surtout que
c'est un poste pour qui ou le psg a
vraiment un problème puisque c'est le
poste faible on rappelle du psg on à
roanne berne hâte à ce poste-là qui est
blessé on a abou diallo qui dépanne en
gros et on n'a pas vraiment de de
titulaire est titulaire en puissance
très important ouais il ya encore il ya
encore layvin kurzawa qui est toujours
au club même si on l'a souvent annoncé
sur le départ et peut-être que ça va se
faire finalement aujourd'hui on verra
bien mais effectivement c'est un peu le
post le poste faiblesse pour le psg juan
bernales qui a encore un petit peu loin
de se remettre de sa blessure et qui
semble normalement être le titulaire
maintenant on verra aussi dans quel état
je crois qu'il a il a passé les trente
ans je crois où il en est pas loin il ya
quand même un certain vécu un certain
passif au niveau des blessures on verra
son niveau abdou diallo qu'il n'est pas
une comme il peut mais effectivement
c'est peut-être le poste aujourd'hui il
ya une faiblesse au psg ils ont réparé
ce problème là avec le poste de latéral
droit avec achraf chili et on voit sur
le début de saison c'est fait c'est être
une très très bonne pioche effectivement
sur la taqiyya rien à dire sur le milieu
de terrain ils sont quand même assez
bien fourni en défense centrale aussi un
gardien un tout autre sujet encore sont
pas mal en fournit aux infos seront bien
fourni peut-être effectivement
effectivement le poste de latéral gauche
c'est peut-être aujourd'hui un peu la
faiblesse du paris saint germain alors
il s'est alors selon les informations de
rmc et de l'équipe différentes sources
on pourrait passer sur un échange en
prêt entre de nos mendes et pablo
sarabia est donc là le psg se
débarrasserait un peu de pablo sarabia
il faut aussi rappeler quelque chose par
rapport au psg c'est que le psg a
beaucoup de joueurs et qu'il cherche à
s'en débarrasser il devait vendre je
sais plus qu'à 180 milles 180 millions
d'euros et pour l'instant ils ont vendu
une chaîne bakker au bayer leverkusen
c'est ça ils ont vendu pour 11 3 7
millions d'euros quelque chose comme ça
alors qu'il avait promis à la dncg le
gendarme financier du football français
de ventes pour 181 millions d'euros
alors peut-être que le mercato d'hiver
sera pris en compte dans ses comptes la
donc forcément ça laissera un peu de
sursis au psg qu'on va pas non plus tiré
la sonnette d'alarmé tout de suite mais
effectivement il ya des joueurs un peu à
désirer l'opg qu'il devait partir les
mots riccardi qui étaient parfois
annoncé à la juventus pablo sarabia fait
partie de ces jours là
aujourd'hui au psg on a du mal à voir
quel temps de jeu il peut espérer
surtout si qui les amap et reste au club
derrière mbappé messi neymar il n'y aura
pas beaucoup de temps de jeu vous
rajoutez à ça en trail di maria julian
draxler qui s'est pas mal relancé aussi
sous mauricio pochettino forcément pour
sera bien c'est un petit peu compliqué
et s'il ya un joueur qui doit partir bas
c'est peut-être lui que le psg 20 petit
peu poussé à la porte pour alléger son
budget sa masse salariale donc
effectivement un échange avec nous nos
mendes ça peut être un moyen de
renforcer ce poste faible ce poste de
latéral gauche et en même temps de
nettoyer un petit peu l'effectif alors
vous n'hésitez pas à continuer à poser
vos questions dans le tchat on va on
essaie d'y répondre toujours pareil on
peut peut-être passé sur une vente du
psg leur semaine une vente du coup c'est
un prêt c'est cali wendo cali mondo le
joueur du psg attaquant plutôt
remplaçant pour le coup parce qu'il ya
quand même du monde un peu devant lui et
qui va repartir à lens il déjà prêté
l'an dernier il est prêté une nouvelle
fois alors cette année oui ça paraît
être assez assez logique parce
qu'effectivement caliendo je crois qu'il
a même pas vingt ans donc c'est plutôt
un bon jeune à un bon espoir mais au psg
c'est très loin d'être suffisant il faut
déjà être un top joueur à cet âge là si
on veut prétendre à du temps de jeu
parce que le pg n'est malheureusement
pas le temps les remplaçants aujourd'hui
remplaçant au psg c'est marc aux
ecardines en tout cas ça va être le cas
lorsque priori mbappé mais cinéma seront
tous en forme c'est quand même un
remplaçant à 50 millions d'euros
effectivement pour cali mundo il ya
encore du boulot s'il veut se faire se
faire sa place au psg
repartir à lens en prêt où ça s'était
bien passé la saison dernière ça paraît
assez cohérent en tout cas il va pour le
développer oui voilà pour lui dans une
haie fit passer à ses joueuses qui a
montré un très beau football la saison
dernière surtout pour un promu qui
paraît encore aujourd'hui être assez
cohérente et jouer en tout cas plutôt la
première partie de tableau en ligue 1
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
finalement pour lui effectivement on
peut peut-être passé sur sur notre club
à notre club français c'est l'olympique
de marseille l'olympique de marseille
avec qui
qui est un peu dans une situation un peu
étrange on va dire parce que il pourrait
acheter des joueurs mais ici cherche à
vendre en fait oui c'est ça alors il ya
notamment un gros sujet aujourd'hui à
l'om c'est celui de la mine à rite qui
s'est déjà entraîné avec l'om qui s'est
quasiment quasiment marseillais mais son
transfert n'a pas été officialisé
pourquoi parce que lohan doit après
youri encore vendre s'il veut pouvoir
l'officialiser via notamment un joueur
qui est annoncé sur le départ c'est
douillet child soeur défenseur croate de
l'om qui aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout
dans les petits papiers de georges sympa
olic est vraiment relégués très bas dans
la hiérarchie des défenseurs
sachant que l'om en avait fait quand
même
l'avait achetée pour le moment c'est ça
oui il y avait vraiment un peu
d'ambition avec lui maintenant il ya eu
une offre a priori de wolverhampton de
18 millions d'euros l'om est d'accord
mais le joueur n'est plus tu n'as plus
très envie de partir notamment pour des
raisons extra-sportives parce qu'il
vient de devenir papa la semaine
dernière qui avec sa famille n'ont pas
forcément envie de déménager maintenant
en angleterre de refaire un peu leur vie
qui se sent pas si mal à marseille
maintenant pour théâtre ça ça paraît
difficile de se relancer et en même
temps l'om l'ol n'en fera
vraisemblablement rien il semble
vraiment vouloir vouloir le vendre alors
on va montrer justement cet effectif de
l'om il ya un autre sujet qui est assez
important aussi à l'om c'est le seul
dossier de boubacar camara boubacar
camara qui est qui qui qui est un grand
espoir de l'om on en parle depuis très
longtemps et qui devait partir et a
priori pour rester oui finalement il va
peut être y là il va peut-être rester
c'est un joueur là aussi en fin de
contrat en juin prochain donc c'est là
aussi pour l'om maintenant ou jamais si
jamais ils veulent ils veulent le vendre
a priori il va rester on va pas dire
contre sa volonté parce que lui en tout
cas il n'y a pas vraiment eu d'infos sur
ce il voulait partir ou rester en tout
cas le sujet d'une prolongation de
contrat il semble complètement au point
mort aujourd'hui
c'est pas une mauvaise chose pour l'om
de le conserver le problème c'est plutôt
une question de budget on l'a vu l'om
n'a pas du tout de fonds illimités c'est
pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont prêtées prêté avec option d'achat
par fois une option une option d'achat
qui est obligatoire qui vaut beaucoup
pensé en termes de de montage financier
du côté du côté de l'om
ne pas réussir à vendre boubacar camara
s'est quand même je pense qu'une petite
déception aux yeux des dirigeants du web
et on en parlait tout à l'heure alors un
autre club
dans notre club de la france c'est
montpellier montpellier qui à andy
delort d'ailleurs a failli partir à l'om
finalement il partait à nice en dise le
donc montpellier qui perd ordi de l'or
qui risque de perdre à priori gaëtan
laborde qui est parti à rennes et qui
pourrait récupérer un ancien de l'om
valère germain oui voilà le pour le coup
le coût est un petit peu dur pour
montpellier parce qu andy delort et
gaëtan laborde c'était une jour
exceptionnel en ligue 1 c'était un jo à
combiner c'était presque 30 buts c'est
vraiment eux qui faisait la taille de
montpellier et qui permettait de lisser
montpellier en première partie de
tableau voire d'en faire un club
crédible pour jouer l'europe là c'est
très dur pour montpellier de perdre les
deux joueurs surtout en fin de mercato
comme ça ils sont pas remplacés et
valère germain va sûrement faire ce
qu'il peut mais aujourd'hui valère jamin
c'est pas gagné laborde plus solide
alors voilà c'est absolument pas ça
c'est je pense même pas gaëtan laborde
ou andy delort malheureusement mais
c'est un joueur qui avait montré de très
bonnes choses à nice à monaco 1-1 l'om
il n'a jamais vraiment réussi à franchir
ce cap il a 31 ans il a été laissé libre
par l'om qui n'a pas voulu prolonger
cc c'est dur pour montpellier de devoir
autant changer son attaque avec a priori
un peu moins de qualité à valère germain
il devrait jouer en attaque du coup avec
steffi maldini qui a montré de bonnes
choses aussi à montpellier mais encore
une fois par rapport à andy delort
gaëtan laborde c'était le jo parfait
pour montpellier ça marchait super bien
c'est vraiment un coup dur je pense pour
pompey est ce que vous voulez redémarre
en fait un nouveau si l'on peut dire est
ce qu'ils feront ils redémarrent une
saison enfin il redémarre un projet on
va dire de nouveau parfum de plus bas et
en essayant de monter oui un petit peu
ils ont ils ont tourné certaines pages
de leur histoire d'abord vitorino hilton
qui naquit à qui met un terme à sa
carrière enfin on aura envie de dire ce
que je crois qu'il a eu il est arrivé à
42 ou 43 ans il avait vraiment tirer sur
la corde jusqu'au bout et c'est
effectivement une page qui se tourne
avec le départ de michel der zakarian du
banc et l'arrivée d'olivier dall'oglio
maintenant le départ de douleur et de la
borde c'est dur à encaisser pour pour
montpellier oui c'est vraiment une page
qui se tourne aujourd'hui pas sûr que
maintenant si on doit faire un pronostic
on mettrait montpellier dans les places
7 8 comme vous pouvez le faire l'année
dernière c'est un effectif qui en fait
quand même pas mal perdu en qualité
vidéo une ride quarante trois ans il va
bientôt en avoir 44 dans une semaine
comme quoi on n'était pas si loin
ensuite dans les clubs et yahia lily
romain febvre de joueurs de brest grand
espoir qui a montré tout son talent je
me rappelle du match en début de saison
contre le psg brest a perdu largement
mais romain febvre a vraiment montré
qu'il était un joueur de foot à sexuelle
la semil on était dessus et finalement
il va rester à brest est quand même une
super nouvelle pour eux oui c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour brest pour le
coup on avait même parlé de lui un petit
peu au psg à la toute fin de saison
dernière en l1 oui c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour brest parce que c'est un
joueur qui a été qui a été plus que
convaincant en ligue 1 qui est un petit
peu surnagé pour le coup on parlait tout
à l'heure de zinédine ferhat à nîmes je
pense que romain febvre est un peu dans
cette trempe-là de joueurs qui a surnagé
dans une équipe qui a parfois eu un peu
du mal à s'en sortir en ligue 1 même si
brest pour le coup il y avait un jeu
assez assez séduisant
c'est vraiment un club qui s'est sauvé
dans l'est dans les toutes dernières
journées c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour brest de garder un élément offensif
aussi forme alors on parle de tous ces
joueurs qui évoluent dans des clubs un
peu faible mais qui sont très forts il y
avait aussi le cas de farid boulahia
farid boulahia du fc metz devait partir
aussi et qui est priori n'a toujours pas
de point de chute à l'heure actuelle way
qui va a priori rester rester à metz
c'est un joueur aujourd'hui un petit peu
un petit peu de vécu en tout cas en
ligue 1 fait partie de ces jours un
petit peu pour prendre un exemple avec
du côté d'angers avec angelo fruits
djinnit on a vu encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup de rumeurs qui sont sortis un
peu en répartir au csk moscou a priori
c'est ça au csk moscou le psv eindhoven
aussi a été a été cités comme
prétendants ça fait partie de ces
joueurs de ligue 1 qui sont quand même
pas mal estimé un petit peu partout en
europe même s'ils sont pas des clubs
très très huppé mais les clubs qui
peuvent qui peuvent jouer l'europe et
sondés sont des joueurs assez précieux
pour pour leur club boulahia est très
importante pour metz faut le génie est
capital pour pour angers dans ce rôle un
peu de numéro 10 derrière derrière les
attaquants sont des joueurs très
importants et se sont effectivement ses
joueurs que un peu tous les supporters
redoutent de perdre au dernier moment
dans les dernières heures du mercato ces
joueurs très créateurs qui peut
effectivement changer toute la face
d'une équipe et si on les perd c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué on à bérénice
qui nous
18 qui me dit bonjour vous salue
bérénice vous avez vu la rumeur de
boateng à l'om ce serait un joli cours
d'un peu partout d'ailleurs
effectivement boateng à l'ol il ya pire
comme tu disais à la fin du mercato que
de trouver boateng à la haye où il ya
les impairs et je pense même que l'on
pourrait se demander si finalement en
défense centrale c'est pas là le
meilleur le meilleur mouvement on
pourrait dire de l'ol s'était dit en
tout cas d'avoir de remplacer marcelo
par boateng c'est plutôt ce plutôt
satisfaisant on avait vu cet été le
recrutement en tout début de mercato de
damien da silva qui était qui était en
fin de contrat je crois à rennes on voit
que pour l'instant damien mais cela n'a
pas du tout lancé sa saison il était
suspendu sur les deux premiers matches
derrière il a joué il a écopé d'un
carton rouge et d'être suspendu de
rendre un match face à je crois que
c'était face à clermont où il a il a
complètement pris l'eau
boateng sur sur le papier oui c'est
vraiment une satisfaction il sort de dix
ans bayern munich il a tout vu il a tout
gagné il a gagné la coupe du monde avec
l'allemagne en terme d'expérience de
vécu de ce qui peut apporter au groupe
et de complémentarité en tout cas je
pense avec son entraîneur peter bosch je
pense que ça peut vraiment match et avec
la rigueur l'exigence qu'il peut
apporter à l'ol qui en tout cas un petit
peu ce que réclamait peter bosch qui
parlait souvent d'un changement de
mentalité je pense que boateng peut tout
à fait à portée ça maintenant la petite
incertitude c'est le physique c'est pour
ça que le bayern ne l'avait pas prolongé
parce que boateng a eu pas mal de
blessures ces derniers temps on se
demande s'il pourra vraiment tenir sur
toute une saison s'il pourra jouer 30 35
matches sur une saison de ligue 1 ça on
verra mais sur le papier c'est vraiment
une un joli coup de l'ol dans les
dernières heures du mercato on avait dit
au site il manquerait quand même à lyon
un vrai numéro 9 pour andré dembélé
dembélé qui comme m fait un début de
saison assez correct alors qu'on
s'attendait pas forcément à ça oui
effectivement alors l'ol voulait ce
numéro 9 avec l'iranien asmo n'diaye
zénith saint pétersbourg ils ont beau
essayer malheureusement le zénith n'a
pas trouvé de remplaçant du coup ils ont
préféré garder leurs joueurs aient
refusé les offres de noël donc l'ol n'a
pas réussi de coup dans les dernières
heures du mercato on parle notamment de
wiljan l'ailier brésilien qui était à
chelsea avant qui est en fin de contrat
à arsenal et qui va finalement à priori
retourner au brésil l'ol va devoir se
contenter entre guillemets de moussa
dembélé dislab si nani ou encore douces
et d'avoir en attaque ça reste quand
même très intéressant sur le papier
maintenant effectivement pour jouer
l'europe pour jouer plusieurs tableaux
ça peut être un petit peu un petit peu
limité mais comme comme tu le disais
vincent / sur le début de saison moussa
dembélé c'est très satisfaisant il
retrouve un petit peu de forme il
sortait de six mois fantomatique à le
psycho de madrid il n'a quasiment pas
joué il n'a pas marqué pour l'instant
moussa dembélé il danse bien sa saison
maintenant est ce qu'il peut faire une
saison complète à ce niveau là et avoir
un rendement régulier et efficace sans
lien on a remi dans les commentaires
youtube qui nous parle de daniel james
daniel james qui a un joueur latéral de
manchester united qui était un grand
espoir dans le sol d'haïti et qui c'est
officiel ça y est assignée à liszt ce
quand même pas mal pour liszt oui c'est
pas mal pour lise ça fait partie de ces
joueurs qu'il faut un petit peu les
frais du du gros recrutement de
manchester united avec jade johnson show
cristiano ronaldo
effectivement manchester devait un petit
peu un petit peu dégraisser c'est un
joueur qui était pas mal qu'elle va
baisser dans la hiérarchie je crois que
c'était la saison par la saison dernière
celle d'avant où il c'était un petit peu
révélé il commençait à se faire sa place
en effet est-ce que ça peut être un
potentiel titulaire on a vite vu ses
limites son manque de régularité mais
que ce n'était pas un joueur qu'on
pouvait avoir comme titulaire en tout
cas si on voulait jouer le titre en
angleterre ou même la ligue des
champions maintenant c'est quand même un
bon joueur qui récupère lisent un jour
je pense encore assez malléable 23 ans
je pense que ça va beaucoup plaire à
marcelo bielsa high yield et je pense
que pour les deux parties pour le coup
c'est plutôt une bonne et bonnes
affaires c'est plutôt c'est plutôt une
réussite effectivement on peut reparler
rapidement un peu des petits transfert
20 des petits transfert des supporters
un peu moins important n'hésitez pas si
vous avez des questions dans le tchat
continuez à nous les poser on va essayer
d'y répondre on a eu des nouvelles d'un
des joueurs que les parisiens
connaissent bien c'est javier pastore
javier pastore qui est un joueur libre
et qui pourrait signer n'importe où
maintenant voyez pourrait signer
n'importe où puisqu'il a résilié son
contrat à l'as rome alors pastore il
sort de deux vraiment de damnés de moi
est d'avoir d'année galère à l'as rome
beaucoup blessé comme ça avait déjà été
un petit peu le cas malheureusement au
psg ça a été très compliqué pour lui à
l'as rome clairement il n'avait plus du
tout sa place il n'arrive plus du tout
enchaîner les matches et même lorsqu'il
jouait de toute façon son rendement
avait beaucoup beaucoup chuté
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune rumeur sur
l'avenir de javier pastore on sait pas
où est ce qu'ils pourraient rebondir est
ce que ce sera en europe est ce que ce
sera ailleurs est ce que ce sera
peut-être en france est ce qu'un club
pour s ceux désignés pour essayer de le
récupérer le problème encore une fois
avec pastore avec beaucoup de joueurs
comme ça un peu comme avec boateng c'est
les prétentions salariales c'est un
joueur qui a gagné un certain montant au
psg est encore à l'as rome forcément
cette intelligence c'est difficile pour
un joueur donné revoir à la baisse du
jour au lendemain
on verra ce qui arrivera pas stories qui
restera vraiment dans un club un peu
important est ce qu'il y aura dans un
pays entre guînes un peu plus exotique
dans un championnat moins compétitifs on
verra bien mais il ya comme une belle
cote il reste ce joueur un peu frissons
extraordinaire qui voilà deux jours ce
numéro 10 un peu argentin a peu à côté
un petit peu romantique chez lui
maintenant c'est on a peut-être un peu
déjà vu le meilleur de javier pastore
son objectif sera de rebondir de se
relancer mais ça paraît quand même pas
très très bien parti on peut parler d'un
autre joueur un ancien du psg c'est
moïse kids with fing qui était en prêt
l'an dernier ils les venets d'everton il
avait été prêté par everton au paris
saint germain il avait fait quand même
assez bien le boulot je crois que
jusqu'à un retour de coville ou du coup
ça allait plus du tout il ya plus de co2
de condition physique c'est assez
impressionnant wizz kid qui s'est engagé
il repart à la juventus voyez retourne à
la juventus donc son club formateur
c'est plutôt intéressant pour pour la
juventus après on verra à quel prix
parce que là le deal est assez compliqué
on parle d'un prêt de deux ans avec une
option d'achat qui s'activera que sous
certaines conditions qui n'ont pas été
dévoilés si l'option d'achat ne s'active
pas c'est pas très cher si jamais seul
qui vive c'est très très cher donc ça va
vraiment on va vraiment dépendre mais
maintenant c'est un joueur il fallait un
peu remplacer le vide laissé par
cristiano ronaldo en attaque à la
juventus on parlait beaucoup de morts
oui car dit on verra s'il cardy se fera
aussi ses soit c'est une possibilité
moss qui ne s'est pas vraiment le même
profil évidemment c'est un joueur qui
peut plus évoluer sur un côté qui a
quand même montré un certain instinct de
buteur au psg on l'a vu performer en
ligue 1 enchaînant un petit peu les
matches c'est un joueur qui a que 21 ans
qui est encore très jeune qui reste un
bel espoir pour pour l'italie maintenant
avait retenu sa place pour lui retrouver
l'environnement d'une juventus qui a
peut-être un petit peu moins d'ambitions
qui est encore un peu en reconstruction
c'est plutôt intéressant maintenant on
verra si ça match avec massimiliano
allegri 6 au football parfois un petit
peu un petit peu sur la défensive
allegri peut vraiment lui convenir si ça
match avec ses partenaires paulo dibala
peut-être mareuil car disent ils de
retrouve lui aussi du coup finalement à
à la juventus c'est quand même une
affaire à suivre c'est un joueur qu'on a
vraiment envie de suivre à la jules
bérénice qui nous dit louise qui n'a 17
millions c'est vraiment cadeau alors ça
va dépendre de effectivement combien ça
coûte vraiment au final cette
transaction oui voilà à 17 millions
effectivement ça paraît plutôt un bon
deal je crois que ça peut monter jusqu'à
38 millions après si c'est sous
certaines conditions sportives on peut
imaginer que ça impliquerait que la
juventus aurait du succès donc peut-être
grâce à maurice qu'il peut être qu'il
faut qu'ils atteignent un certain nombre
de buts ou à voir si c'est le cas on
dira peut-être que finalement les 38
millions ils sont justifiés que c'est
logique on verra bien mais en tout cas
pour deux ans si c'est pour 10 15
millions c'est plutôt un bon coup tenté
par là j'ai joué les père et nulle part
aussi dû comparaître pastore un milieu
avec pastore et gourcuff rien que pour
rigoler c'est effectivement un milieu
très créatif mais très souvent blessé où
il n'y a pas souvent tout le monde les
lieux je fais un peu ce serait un peu
compliqué on peut parler d'un petit
transfert du bayern munich qui on n'en
parle pas beaucoup en général ils font
pas les gros titres
dumarquez transfert et ils ont ils ont
récupéré sa vie de faire sa vie de serre
and autrichien qui a prouvé qu'il était
un très très bon joueur à leipzig ça
quand même tout du très bon coup de
bella de munich comme elle a comme à son
habitude oui c'est assez impressionnant
7 cette propension chez le bayern munich
a recruté des joueurs souvent pour des
prix assez faible en plus chez les
concurrents en allemagne ils ont souvent
pillé le borussia dortmund l'affrètement
malheureusement c'est les psy ch
marseille ça bitzer c'était le capitaine
de l'epci ch la saison dernière c'est un
joueur qui a vraiment pris du poids dans
l'animation offensive dans le coeur du
jeu même qui a montré une certaine
polyvalence un peu dans plusieurs
compartiments c'est un genre qui pèse
très lourd en france yves mans qui a une
leader avec la sélection autrichienne il
a 27 ans il dans la fleur de l'âge c'est
un gros coup réalisé par le bayern
munich pour seulement seulement 15
millions d'euros c'est une somme
franchement assez dérisoire par rapport
au niveau qu'à afficher sa vie de serre
en bundesliga ou voir même en ligue des
champions les psychés aller assez - il
croit qu'il avait fait un quart de
finale en 2020 contre contre l'atlético
de madrid domine finalement derrière
c'est un joueur qui peut vraiment
renforcer une équipe sans montrer un un
caractère difficile donc c'est un joueur
qui ne devrait pas poser problème dans
le vestiaire qui va retrouver en plus
julian la gueule semaine son entraîneur
à leipzig on peut franchement être assez
optimiste sur sa réussite au bayern
c'est vraiment un très très bon coup du
on parlait du très beau coup de moïse
qui n'a 17 millions je pense que sa vie
de sarah 15 c'est quand même aussi pas
mal du coup je pense que même c'est
encore un petit peu au dessus c'est
vraiment un très très bon coup dans
cette dans cette fin de mercato très
bien et bien écoutez merci beaucoup
d'avoir été nombreux à nous suivre vous
êtes encore assez nombreux on a répondu
à toutes vos questions voilà vous allez
le compte à rebours kehl à 6h10 il reste
six de leurs 10 avant la fin du mercato
un mercato qui on le sait dans les
dernières heures s'emballe un peu en
général même si en terme de deux gros
dossiers il n'y en a plus tant que ça on
pourrait me citer quoi ah koon des kundé
griezmann félix oui peut-être boateng le
temps que ce soit officialisé le cas
aussi de came having a bien sûr
peut-être marwijk a redit si finalement
il quitte le psg ou pas voilà c'est un
petit peu les gros dossiers qu'on pourra
suivre cajetan laborde aussi s'il n'a
pas encore été officialisé sa n'a pas
encore l'étoffé d'un rennes pourra être
aussi à suivre effectivement effective
alors on à rémy qui demande si on va
être en live jusqu'à la fin du mercato
malheureusement non on va s'arrêter
bientôt même on vous fait face à six
heures de live malheureusement mais vous
pouvez continuer de suivre le mercato
sur le site du figaro vous avez le live
sur le site du mercato que vous pouvez
suivre effectivement avec toutes les
dernières informations voilà vous le
voyez à l'écran avec je crois que
c'était l'information concernant bella
nova villa nova de girondins de bordeaux
qui a été prêté à cagliari on n'a pas
parlé parce que c'est pas des ehpad et
des dégâts des grans tarbes on parle des
joueurs un peu plus impressionnant ce
abyss est originaire de grâce comme
arnold schwarzenegger voilà on appris
quelque chose aujourd'hui moi je ne sais
pas je le savais pas merci bérénice
merci à vous d'avoir été nombreux à nous
suivre pour ce live moi je vous dis à
bientôt et
et voilà bientôt merci sébastien une
nouvelle fois pour sion et suivez le
mercato plus que six heures à tenir pour
les fans de foot bon courage à vous